bitte bitte bitte von meine freunde der
leichten unterhaltung wir spielen die
nächste folge galaxy mit dem contractor
hannover und dem gegner aber ich bin ich
bin nur als geist da musst du das sagen
einfach mit weil das ist ja wir alle und
schnell kennen könnte ist in der letzten
folge gleich zweimal gestorben
das ist will das ist liebe leute das ist
auch möglich dass totalen das hat nicht
jeder fündig und deswegen bin ich bin
ich auch ganz froh dass diese
fähigkeiten sich in meiner
kleinen aber feinen personen vereine bei
mir regnet gerade habe mir gerade das
ist noch nicht so weit voneinander weg
ihr seid ihr jetzt im gegnerischen team
ihr seht ihr wesen nicht und das ist das
was muss man da zu erwähnen dass wir
also oder jetzt eigentlich ihr beide
gerade eben gegeneinander seit aber
trotz allem redet ihr miteinander wie
wir sind nicht so weit voneinander weg
ich glaube es sind 10.000 blöcke ich
glaube jetzt mal los an deiner stelle
okay okay hier hast du irgendeine
empfehlung für mich was ich mir so einen
essen holen könnte weil ich habe jetzt
kein eisen ich mir jetzt auch nicht wenn
das so weiß er es gerade am regnen ist
ich hatte gerade eben bzw in der ersten
folge hat kuka glaube ich bei uns sich
so stroh es gibt irgendwie immer auf der
website rennt im strom menschen oder so
die ganze abbauen
stroh menschen jetzt sowieso ein strom
mensch strom menschen beinstein menschen
beim strom menschen beim stroh statuen
und die ganze zeit abbauen ist rudern
und dann brot ich habe ich hab noch nie
kann sein dass bei euch andere sachen
sind als bei uns ich habe noch nie ein
strom menschen gesehen hier vielleicht
liegt auch an meine dass ich jeden tag
rund um ihre aber ich bin mir sicher
jeder gibt's da gibt's wirklich welcher
das habe ich meiner test welt gesehen
die ich im singleplayer gemacht haben
facebook page oder swiss rausgerutscht
bei diesen ist köthen ein bisschen für
diskussion sorgen deswegen ja so ein
bisschen wie ich brauche wirklich was zu
essen aber ich finde ja nichts weiß ich
hab so war unfassbar viele samen und
hier ist richtig viel wasser aber ich
habe einfach auch kein eisen weil ich
keine höhle finde ich traue mich nicht
in der höhle ich habe hole ich hab eine
höhle gefunden das ist unglaublich
das mittel zusammen ich glaube da muss
ich direkt meine gitarre auspackt mit
ihren songs spielen oder
nur beteiligen keine keine sorge dass
mich aber ich bin jetzt ein skelett dann
nämlich das skelett wenn ich das töten
wird dich das geld tötet bist tot aber
wenn du das skelett würdest dann bist du
uns gelehrt so muss aber sehen immer
positiv denken
ich bin in skelett jetzt anderes glätte
an die aussagen der luca hat einen bmi
von fünf der iss starten dies gilt auch
e mail immer wenn ich jetzt irgendwo ein
blogger unter gehörig ins gletscher und
ach nee nee ich sterbe gerade an hunger
das ist es gott heiligen oder jahr hieß
auch schon alles abgefahren bei uns das
richtig schlimm
ich hoffe mal steht marco eisen auch
sehr schön ich hatte aufweisen dann bin
ich gestorben und ich bin jetzt karten
krieg explodiert und es ist echt so
komisch wenn man dieses gletscher sound
hat bisher wenn sie ein skelett am
sterben also dieses kann das für euch ja
die ganze zeit war ich einfach ein
skelett bin dabei weiß aber dass du das
wieder zwischen kanzler werden mit
welchen knopf denn neben dem
fragezeichen und der tastatur diese das
kleine apostroph da kannst du drauf
klicken dann müsste sich oben links und
unfällen zu öffnen
da kann es einem durch scrollen raster
schön ich bin wieder ich okay ich hab
ein halber die herz dann wenn er sich
selbst auch ich grad ist tot ich bin tot
da hat es geschafft er holt jetzt auf
erholt jetzt auf dem immer wieder
hinterher
das ist richtig toll gemacht schön wie
man einfach immer nach eifers ja und ich
lasse das jetzt nicht alleine so dumm
dastehen ich gehe direkt nach und in der
zweiten episode wohl gestorben bindet
sagt personen mülleimer figur oder hörst
und dann stirbt er ja einfach nur dass
er professionell genug
russell die tat war du ich hab gesagt du
bist eine müll geburt dass du dir bin
ich einfach ja freunde würden
eingefroren
ich bin jetzt hier keine ahnung wo muss
ich hin
ich sehe nur wasser leute das ist jetzt
echt nicht schön meine ganze sache ich
hatte alles dabei was ich erreicht habe
ich sitze so traurig denn ich hatte
alles dabei was ich erreicht habe
das ist jetzt mal so traurig vor allem
dass deshalb das tolle ist es einfach
wenn ich jetzt das werden wir jetzt
einfach noch mal sterben dass kann sogar
stark sein weil ihr richtig soll ich
kann der server admin kann dich porten
wenn du willst ja ja schreibt mal bitte
das wäre superschön wenn ich bis dahin
nicht direkt wieder tot bin
hier kommt wieder zum licht auf mich
zugestürmt
gerade am anfang das wirklich schwierig
also besonders ich finde auch es gibt
richtig richtig ekelhaft viele mops vinz
bewirbt es ist immer dunkel ist einfach
mal regnen
ich glaub ich hab eine möglichkeit
gefunden die mob zu töten ich stelle
mich einfach auf eine überlegene
position und boxee ist jetzt du bist
jetzt vielleicht auch noch ein zweites
mal
neben dem moment nicht luca porten
schnell mich porten richtig schnell mich
porten es hat aufgehört zu regnen und es
ist auch unwahrscheinlich
heilige mutter gottes ponor hier noch
mal angenehm einer konnte mich porten
schnell mich porten
was passiert bald silikon gefunden ich
sehe große brüste
ich hätte der kinder schreibt einfach
luca nicht porten der will nicht weg
jedoch schreibt das jetzt mal also nicht
das nie dass ich gepokert werden will
ich verzeihe mir ist mich verfolgt
sondern zombie mit einem kopf auf den
kopf die musst du andere ja ich habe
definitiv geschrieben dass das wirklich
gleich boden sollen geht das ja und das
steht ich tue es ja natürlich ich habe
geschrieben dass also ich habe die
situation beschrieben und meine meinung
dazu und meine meinung dazu
wie viel hast du noch zweieinhalb hier
ist eine gute zahl über hunger hat man
sich über eine 25 in der schule gefreut
ich weiß nicht was beispiel roosters
bitte bitte bitte bitte ich würde ich es
echt lieben jetzt bin ich in münchen
es ist wundervoll ist man ja noch
richtig klein
ich glaube ich bin auch als frühchen
gestorben reifen einen zombie ist
eigentlich an wenn man zombies
aber ich kann schneller schwimmen oder
selbst bei mir war das ganz komisch weil
ich habe davor als mensch schon mops
gespottet quasi während dann habe ich
mich verwandelt aber das haben sie dann
glaube ich gecheckt soweit konnten die
denken ja so krass wenn ich so klein
denn du weißt du wie schumi und ich uns
die ganze zeit fühlen ja das ist richtig
ich wachse ich wachse ich wachse ich
habe sachen einrichtung halb so jetzt
erst mal schauen was geht aus ihr
geschrieben hat
lukat kann ihn jemand porten moment luca
steht glaube ich gleich noch mal nicht
pforten
klickt euch hortet mich sogar sei noch
nicht immer so unhöflich
der grund warum ich niemand mag ich
hatte gar keine zeit gerade bin
unterwegs super und ich werde
wahrscheinlich von trani irgendwie noch
gefordert denn in der nächsten folge bei
mir das kann schon mal sagen wir dass
sturm dabei sind vielleicht auch der
kran ich wende mich port muss er
natürlich auch mit kommentieren die alte
kanülen und es hat super ist über lustig
und dann gehen gerade und ich auf jagd
nach sturm und bei mir von morgen ja
weil du bist tot
das wären sechs uns einfach absolut
immer in einer anderen folge von uns
jemand interesse abwechselnd folgen auf
den fans kommt also quasi in jeder folge
sterben wir im prinzip wir stellen
einfach in jeder folge deswegen müsse
die dazu gezwungen dass ihr immer
abwechselnd mir schaut und umwelt ist
eben anderen team was ich übrigens sehr
schade finde ja finde ich auch aber es
war ja viel viel hin und her mit den
teams hervor und ich bin ja nach wie vor
froh dass wir wenigstens mit anderen
fraktionen aufnehmen können das heißt ja
ich werde auch ab und an mal bei euch
mit special naja ich bin zu hause
aber der fraktion danke lang geholt als
kanal übrigens ich habe vorher meine
instagram fotos entschuldigen so schön
ich glaube es das beste instagram profil
der welt jedoch sahen heiße ich da auf
twitter ist auch diese woche und ich
habe shirts und mützen wenn ich spielen
muss dann nutze ich den moment auch den
fischen eingefügte schleichwerbung und
in unserem in unserem anfangs gebäude
war sein ofen drin da wären einmal 13
eisen drin ja mensch du das ist schön
jetzt auch mal raus zu ihr steht doch
direkten bett darin dass er nicht mit
guck mal die nummer kann auch t shirts
waffel t shirts jacken ist wunderschön
ich habe keine t-shirts die politiker zu
sendern dann male ich zeigen was drauf
oder so sie die sexy aus strafe durch
das leiste ich mir zu übernächsten
ostern oder so
es kostet so wie die anderen t shirts
auch beides kostet der tarif bis 17 euro
und wenn man dann natürlich sagt ich
möchte wirklich dass stella likes girlie
shirt dann kostet das 19 90
da mache ich einfach ein video dann
kaufe ich mir direkt 1000 davon weiß ja
so schnappauf jedenfalls einen
schneidigen bus braucht man auch ich
finde ich irgendwie was dafür aber ich
kann sogar keinen stress denn gerade
eben hier dass er hat man also wirklich
stunde hier richtig bis mäßig am
liebsten lässt er weiß wie es geht
ich habe die richtigen text eingepackte
silikon und brüste und zack in die t
shirt weg wie nix leute das ist doch
nicht mehr normal ich muss irgendwie
nach hause kommen jetzt neue saison
stockfinster draußen und ich habe
vergessen
oh wie ist das schön was zu essen her
das projekt hatte ich mal wieder so ein
anfang der ist total chaotisch aber
super ja ein chaotischer aber super
dollar an werken
ich komme wirklich angelaufen
bitte wieder einig werden bitte direkt
geschickt
sturm ich weiß und dann völlig auf
markus lanz auch am montag kommt bieten
sich natürlich warum ich in 20 jahren
fielen
was ist was passiert wenn ich dann ging
es zum gehirn das ist also das ist ich
glaube wir müssen kurz vergiftet wenn
ich sie hier
ich will so drachen eintracht musste ich
ganz gut drauf setzen ja das ist einfach
zu uns ja genau deswegen ihr könnt auch
einfach eine fledermaus töten könnt ihr
auch fliegen das hat er nie in der
ersten folge 8000 betont und wir sitzen
hier so ja wir haben gerade ein haus
gebaut
ich würde nicht mehr einkriegen vor den
boxen überhaupt event conny und ich ihm
spaß so ein paar kleine seitenhiebe
gegenüber anderen youtube und in dem
projekt bringen dann ist das natürlich
weil wir die abgrundtief assen nähe ist
es nicht sondern weil wir weil er gerne
beziehen machen
wir hatten ja stimmt es nicht böse
das geht wirklich dementi mitleid habe
ich mich schon gefragt würde dass du
mich schon gefragt in der letzten
episode denkt doch mal nach man aber man
ist das traurig dass einfach morgen
keine folge kommen
mich so darauf gefreut hier kommen
erfolge sind kombis bei mir richtig
vollkommen korrekt spiel übrigens grad
rubik's cube auf google das ist nämlich
gerade irgendwie lux kino weil ich den
rubik's cube magische brüssel
er ist wird aber ganz schön ganz schön
traurig luca ich weiß was ich aber du
meinst also so komisch betont kann man
dass das spiel hat nur gesehen dass
googles design hat bei der ja ja und wie
oft bist dann kannst du da tatsächlich
mit spielen und es macht mir viel spaß
ich bin etwas richtig viel minesweeper
ich verstehe das spiel zwar nicht aber
es ist irgendwie schön wenn hätten
bomben explodieren
du verstehst das spiel nicht minesweeper
so schwierig zu verstehen
das hat ein komplexes regelwerk als
wahre alter der eltern erstmal ohne spaß
ist das ist ich finde das total schwer
ich kann muss man dahin klicken wenn die
zahlen auftauchen ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit höher dass da etwas
besonderes ist weiß ich nicht keine
ahnung was mich nur 100 wieder die folge
beenden also die zahlen drum herum
zeigen wir an wie viele minen in deiner
umgebung sind und was für den abstand ja
okay das war das spiel damit habe ich
jetzt glaube ich deine deine welt
erleuchtet oder persönlich verstehen wir
nicht also ich finde sich eure welt zu
erleuchten mir ich soll doch diese
spiele damals früh raus holt doch ich
glaube aus krisengebieten heraus habe
ich mir so ein ding bestellt ihr könnt
auch diese diese ultraschall
fliegenfischer vertreibt dinge die so
laut durch die gegend quietschen und hab
ich mir jetzt mal so richtig ist
hardcore teil bestellt wo sogar die
frequenz einstellen kann damit die sich
nicht dran gewöhnen und habe das fenster
offen und das kameralicht jahr an
und trotzdem ist nix im raum ja also
bitteschön hammer
das ist der hammer ja ich werde dafür
dass wir langsam die folge werden weil
wir gehen schon über die 15 minuten
gerade nicht so toll und ich hab mein
bett gesetzt das heißt ich spanne hier
kein du wieder da bei unserer base bis
dann kann es ja auch einfach mal den
betten abbauen und zudem mit
ich werde erst mal ich irgendwas wird
passieren in der nächsten folge bei mir
ich bin mir sicher wir sonst gut wer mit
sich schon überzogen das war jetzt aus
versehen ich habe mich auf die zeit
geachtet das hat auch seinen teil an
das auge mit aufnimmt einen
wunderschönen dank ansturm wie heute
dabei weil es wird auf jeden fall noch
öfters vorkommen dass wir fraktions
übergriffen übergreifend aufnehmen und
zunächst als texter des sturmes voll
super kombis abonnenten geht man zur
sturm vorüber
damit macht tolles zeug das wollte ich
auch erwähnen